And Live Claritin clear.
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR FINAL
EXAM WHERE WE DETERMINE THROUGH
RIGOROUS TESTING WHICH OF OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE WORK THEY DO THIS WEEK'S
DEFENDING CHAMPION IS FOX NEWS
CORRESPONDENT GRIFF JENKINS
STILL INJURED BUT STILL RAZOR
SHARP.
HIS CHALLENGER, FOX BUSINESS
CORRESPONDENT KRISTINA.
WELCOME TO FOX AND TO THE SHOW.
WE'RE REALLY GLAD TO HAVE YOU.
>> THANK YOU, I'M EXCITED.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: OK, SO YOU KNOW WHO
YOU'RE UP AGAINST.
>> KRISTINA IS BRILLIANT.
SHE SPEAKS FIVE LANGUAGES.
I'M DOOMED.
>> Tucker: HE UNDERSELLS IT
EVERY TIME.
I'M SURE YOU KNOW THE RULES
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN GLUED TO
THIS.
IN CASE YOU NEED A REFRESHER,
HERE THEY ARE.
THE FIRST PERSON TO BUZZ AND GET
THE ANSWER -- YOU MUST WAIT
UNTIL I FINISH ASKING THE
QUESTION IN ORDER TO BUZZ IN.
EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS WORTH A
SINGLE POINT.
IF YOU GET A QUESTION WRONG, A
POINT IS DETRACTED FROM YOUR
TOTAL.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> I'M READY.
LET'S DO IT.
>> Tucker: QUESTION ONE, THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTS
THIS WEEK AMAZON THE COMPANY MAY
NOW TERMINATE YOUR ACCOUNT IF
YOU DO WHAT TOO OFTEN?
HOLY SMOKES!
>> SHE'S ON FIRE.
>> TOO MANY REFUNDS.
YOU RETURN TOO MANY ITEMS.
SEND THEM BACK.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> UH-HUH.
>> Tucker: ROLL TAPE.
>> SOME AMAZON CUSTOMERS SAY
THEY WERE BANNED FROM THE SITE
FOR MAKING TOO MANY RETURNS.
I KNOW PEOPLE IN THAT CATEGORY.
>> ACCORDING TO "WALL STREET
JOURNAL," DOZENS OF USERS HAVE
HAD THEIR ACCOUNTS CANCELLED
WITHOUT WARNING AND AREN'T ALLOW
TO --
>> I COVERED THIS STORY FOR FOX
BUSINESS NEWS.
>> Tucker: THE DECISIVENESS OF
THAT SLAP WAS IMPRESSIVE.
>> IT WAS STRONG.
>> Tucker: LET'S SEE IF YOU
CAN GET ON THE GROUND, TOO.
MAKING ME NERVOUS.
QUESTION TWO.
THERE WAS A HAIRY SITUATION THIS
WEEK IN SAN ANTONIO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT.
A WILD ANIMAL GOT LOOSE AND RAN
AROUND THAT FACILITY.
WHAT KIND OF ANIMAL WAS IT?
GRIFF JENKINS?
>> A -- LET ME THINK.
I GOT GET MY APE SPECIES, IT WAS
A BABOON.
>> Tucker: A BABOON.
WOW, THAT'S SPECIFIC.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO SAY
LEMUR.
WAS IT A BABOON?
ROLL THE TAPE.
>> THERE WAS JUST ONE MONKEY
WANDERING AROUND THE AIRPORT
HOLE.
THE RISI MACOCK WAS CONFINED TO
THE AREA AWAY FROM PASSENGERS.
IT TOOK DOZENS OF ANIMAL WORKERS
AN HOUR TO CAPTURE THE ELUSIVE
GUY.
>> Tucker: THIS IS -- I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY'RE CALLED.
WE HAVE A WHOLE PANEL OF JUDGES.
DID THEY JUST DING YOU?
>> THEY DINGED ME.
THEY DINGED ME COME ON ARM.
COME ON ARM.
THIS IS TOUGH.
>> Tucker: OUR JUDGES DID JUST
SAID DUE TO TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES, YOUR TOTAL IS NOT
REFLECTED ON THE SCREEN BUT IT'S
ONE TO NEGATIVE ONE.
>> I HAVE A LOT OF WAY TO GO.
THIS MAY BE IT.
>> Tucker: WE'RE THE FINAL
CALL HERE.
QUESTION THREE, ONE OF THE MOST
TALKED-ABOUT MOMENTS AT THE
ROYAL WEDDING WAS A PERFORMANCE
BY THE KINGDOM CHOIR.
THEY SANG A GOSPEL VERSION OF
WHICH 1960'S CLASSIC SONG?
>> I HEARD IT.
I WATCHED IT!
>> "STAND BY ME."
>> Tucker: "STAND BY ME."
IS THAT CORRECT?
♪ STAND BY ME.
STAND BY ME.
STAND BY ME ♪
>> THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT
THEY HAD "STAND BY ME."
>> Tucker: I DIDN'T SEE THE
WEDDING BUT THAT WAS NICE.
0-1.
YOU'RE COMING BACK.
THIS IS MULTIPLE CHOICE, NEW
YORK CITY MAYOR BILL DEBLAZE YO
IS BACKING A PROPOSED BILL THIS
WEEK THAT WOULD BAN WHICH
PLASTIC PRODUCT FROM ALL CITY
RESTAURANTS?
IS IT A, BOTTLES?
B, UTENSILS?
C, STRAWS?
GRIFF JENKINS?
>> I'M GUESSING HERE, STRAWS.
>> Tucker: STRAWS.
IS IT STRAWS?
>> ADVOCATES SAY TOO MANY STRAWS
END UP IN LANDFILLS AND THE
OCEANS.
ONE OF THE PROPOSED BILL
RESTAURANTS AND FAST-FOOD CHAINS
WOULD BE BARRED FROM GIVING
STRAWS OUT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW HOW WE
FOUND OURSELVES IN THE FINAL
ROUND IN SUDDEN DEATH TIED 1-1.
I TOLD YOU, KRISTINA.
SORT OF THE LAID-BACK POLITENESS
AND PHYSICAL INCAPACITATION.
FINAL QUESTION, READY?
DURING A YALE COMMENCEMENT
SPEECH ON SUNDAY, HILLARY
CLINTON, FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE, TRIED HER HAND AT PROP
COMEDY BY PUTTING ON WHAT KIND
OF HAT?
GRIFF JENKINS?
>> A RUSSIAN HAT.
>> Tucker: A RUSSIAN HAT?
>> Tucker: KIND OF WARM FOR
THAT, ISN'T IT?
DOES THE TAPE BACK UP GRIFF
JENKINS?
>> A RUSSIAN HAT.
>> Tucker: IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A GREAT JOKE IF SHE DIDN'T SAY
ANYTHING AND JUST PUT IT ON HER
HEAD!
>> I LOVE THE WAY THAT HILLARY
IS NOW DOING VISUAL COMEDY.
I THINK VLADIMIR PUTIN SHOULD
MAKE CHEAP COMMENTS ON THAT.
>> Tucker: JUST ONE OF THOSE
VALUABLE LESSONS ABOUT WORKING
HERE AT FOX, KRISTNIA, I KNOW
THAT YOU WILL BE HERE A LONG
TIME AS YOU KNOW IT.
>> IN THE END, SHE'LL BE
REPORTING FROM WASHINGTON HERE.
>> Tucker: I LOVE THAT.
GREAT.
WELCOME.
GREAT TO MEET YOU.
GRIFF, HERE IS THE MUG, UNDER A
ROW.
>> DO YOU HAVE MANY?
WANT TO GIVE THIS ONE TO ME?
>> Tucker: HE'S GOT MANY.
>> I'VE GOT A COLLECTION OF
THEM.
ME AND THE SLING, I'M COLLECTING
THEM ALL.
THAT'S IT FOR THIS WEEK, FOLLOW
THE NEWS EACH AND EVERY WEEK TO
SEE IF YOU CAN BEAT OUR EXPERTS
HERE AT FOX.
WE'RE BACK NEXT THURSDAY.
MEMORIAL DAY WILL BE AIRING THE